اهلا بكم الى موجز الاخبار قتل سبعه
اسرائيليين وجرح 10 في هجوم المسلح شانه
فلسطينيه في قلب الحي الاستيطانيه يعقوب
شمالي القدس المحتله وصفاته الشرطه
بالاعنف من نوعه منذ اعوامه واشار
التحقيقات النوليه للشرطه الاسرائيليه الى
ان الشاب الذي يشتبه انه من القدس
اسرائيليه اطلق النار من مسدس بينما كان
يقود سيارته قرب كنيسه وسط الحيطان
عقب عمليه القدس اصدر وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي اوامره لحمايه المستوطنات
والاستعداد اي تطورات بدنيه اخرى في حينا
توعد وزير الامن القومي اتمار بنزيرا برد
قوي وبتغيير الاوامر المنظمه لاطلاق النار
وعمليه القدس بانها هجوم قاسم ومن اصعب ما
مرت به اسرائيل خلال السنوات الاخيره
واضاف انه تم اتخاذ قرارات بشان عده
اجراءات فوريه ردا على هذا الهجوم
في تونس صار لنا الاتحاد العامه للشغل عن
اعداده لما سماها مبادره انقاذ وطني
بالاشتراك مع هيئه المحامين ورابطه حقوق
الانسان والمنتدى التونسي للحقوق
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه ولما ترشح بعد
تفاصيل المبادره او بنودها لكنها وفق
العاملين عليها ستعرض على الرئيس قيس سعيد
من جهه قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني في
تونس احمد نجيب الشابي ان اهم طرف في
الازمه الحاليه هو الرئيس قيس سعيد الذي
انقض على الدستور والحريات حسب تعريف
قال الرئيس الاوكرانيين تاخر الوصول
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه حتى شهر اغسطس
المقبل سيعني وصولها بعد فوات الاوانه
واضاف ان بلاده بحاجه اسلحه جديده في اسرع
وقت
بدوره قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
بلاده تتوقع وصول الدبابات الالمانيه
والاوروبيه في وقت قصير نسبي لمساعده
اوكرانيا واضاف ان وصول الدبابات
الامريكيه ابرام سيستغرق وقت اطول لكنه
واشنطن ستبدا بتدريب الاوكرانيين عليها
قريبا
قال المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان بلاده تريد الحصول على
طائرات اف 16 لانها متعدده الاستخدامات
واضاف ان القوات الجويه اقرت قائمه
للتيارين الذين سيتولون مهمه الطلعات بتلك
الطائرات اذا وصلت الينا
في موسكو وقالت المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ان تزويد الغرب الاكياف بالدبابات
سيؤدي الى رفع المواجهه بين روسيا والغرب
الى مستوى جديد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]